all of stovepipes lieutenants are dead
and we now know that he's been setting
up a base for Natalia on Coney Island
we still don't know what she's planning
so hopefully we make it there before
it's too late
[Music]
Zachary stovepipe BT possessed a unique
and dangerous fascination with
explosives that would eventually shape
his path in unexpected ways
trained as an explosive Ordnance
disposal Specialist or EOD he initially
immersed himself in the study of
demolitions out of sheer passion
while his primary Duty was to neutralize
explosive threats stovepipe Sensational
curiosity let him down a dark path
as he delved deeper into his field
stovepipe's obsession with the
destructive power of explosives grew he
meticulously collected schematics
prototypes and classified information on
increasingly unstable improvised
explosive devices
he pushed the boundaries of his
knowledge exploring the most hazardous
and volatile designs all in the pursuit
of a fascination with watching the world
burn
surprisingly stovepipe's unorthodox
collection didn't lead to the expected
consequences instead of facing a court
martial for his dangerous hobby his
commanding officer recognized the
potential value of his expertise and
connection
this recognition ultimately sparked an
unexpected turn of events when the Black
task took notice of stowpipe's unique
skills and approached him with an
intriguing proposition
the black tusks saw in stovepipe a
person who shared their desire to
exploit chaos for their own game
they recognized his uncanny ability to
navigate the world of destructive
technology and the potential for him to
come a valuable asset in their
operations
drawn to the Allure of power stovepipe
accepted the invitation to join the
ranks of the Black Tusk
it was within this organization that his
expertise and explosives would find its
true purpose
in position inventory assessment
complete how are we looking on mortars
even with the two new teams we have more
than enough to maintain control of the
shipping lanes that's very good
let me know if we need to pull in
additional resources we'll do but
honestly this feels like Overkill to
secure the river better to Overkill than
be killed
funny you need anything else from me not
at this time stovepipe can't you just
call me Zach wouldn't be professional
stovepipe I hate that nickname most
people hate their nicknames you didn't
make Faye take a nickname say it was
special
and what am I reliable
on Coney Island snowpipe updates Natalya
on the status of the setup including the
mortar launchers that they'll be using
to keep hold of the river
why do you want to know that
professional curiosity no there is no
way to use dirty bombs in our mortar
launchers without contaminating the
launcher that's what I thought I just
wanted confirmation I don't like this
hypothetical question it's just a
question it's a [__] up question
that's the world is this about St Louis
what do you know about St Louis
dirty bomb attack on a convoy rumors
conjecture and fear-mongering to keep
people from moving through the Midwest
you sure letting me sort through the
propaganda you just keep digging through
that Intel and see if there's anything
we can use
you got it boss
why humor me there is no safe way to
house this [__] long-term short term do
you care if people die of course
then concrete lead concrete and
lead-lined crates that no one touches
without full radioactive protection at
all times with decontamination showers
after then deconstruct destroy and bury
the launchers after use
it doesn't make sense
the risk isn't worth it unless you want
people to die of radiation poisoning
thank you stovepipe seriously
is this about St Louis was that us it
was not us so it's true
St Louis happened of course it happened
why did you lie to me you didn't need to
know
these columns are obviously from before
stovepipes Outburst in the cons that we
heard while hunting down anti he brings
up Saint Louis twice and Natalia even
admits to lying about the events that
happened there this on top of Natalia's
questions about radiation and dirty
bombs he is right to be nervous
if this is what Natalia is planning
agents realize they need to close in on
his position and fast
when agents arrived on the island it 'll
quiet too quiet
in fact there were no enemies at all and
senses indicate that the stovepipe
hasn't moved since the agents arrived
eventually they would catch up to
stovepipe except someone had beat them
to it he was already dead
it was a trap
from the Black Tusk coppercraft in the
distance a swarm of drones as well as a
couple of marauder-class quadcopters
were launched on the agent's position
agents attempt to reach the extraction
point but wave after wave of drones mini
tanks warhounds automated turrets and a
heap of emps are blocking their way
they managed to quickly push through but
before Torres is able to pick them up
there is one small enemy that needs to
be removed
but don't let the name fool you that
[__] is Satan's hellhound and
here I go a little off story and break
the immersion my wife uh Slash manager
told me I should probably remove this
part because it's a little bit off brand
but I promised a few of you that I
wouldn't hold back on my emotions and
true feelings about this part of the
mission so the following are actual
clips of my first few playthroughs let's
just call this an intermission but feel
free to skip forward a minute or so to
continue the story just [__] off but for
sake avocado
a sec
why
ah
hey you're the brother jump on for a few
minutes just to finish off the main hunt
won't take long yeah man give me a
moment why does he keep chasing me what
the [__] is wrong with this damn thing
you got this he's actually not so bad
when you're not taking Chase bow are you
dead again yeah um yeah yeah I am
the fact that his name is Sparkles only
makes it that much worse
after the agents managed to put a stop
to the final Target on Coney Island
comfortably definitely without getting
close to rage quitting several times
Torres was about to come in and extract
them however this is when the true depth
of this situation really came to light
while the agents have been playing at
the dog park the Black Tusk have
attacked the White House
it all makes sense now stovepipe and the
whole attack on Coney Island was just a
distraction
over was waiting until the agents were
off site before taking down the network
and then attacking the White House
the only reason they are able to
communicate and use skills now is
because of Wally's mobile shd server
fighting through the outskirts agents
make their way through the Black Tusk
forces to meet up with Kelso at the
White House
as the agents make it to the gates they
watch as several Black Tusk helicopters
depart with one of them carrying the
perfusion bioreactor
at the compound they come across a
Razorback that has been set up on the
White House lawn
after a surprisingly short encounter
given what has been experienced through
this Manhunt so far agents would make
their way through to the White House
alongside Alani Kelso
what they've found was a massacre
while all of the black tasks had cleared
out from the compound the agents were
left with the Stark reality of what had
just occurred
along with many others Captain Lewis had
given his life to protect the jtf and
the base of operations
through Echoes on site the agents were
able to see that Lewis had made the
ultimate sacrifice in order to give many
the time to escape and hide with
Schaefer
while Lewis was comfortably holding his
own it would seem that one of Natalia's
Hunters was able to sneak up on him and
take him down by surprise
Kelso and agent Sanders someone we
haven't seen since the Pentagon Mission
approached the Panic Room
dear Schaefer and many have been hiding
out
Shaffer needs to be returned to his bed
and while on their way many and Kelso
discussed how the black task was able to
take down the network
many acknowledges that he overheard
someone saying that countermeasures
worked perfectly they know that Shaffer
was the target but as long as they have
the mobile shd server while Limited in
range their skills and comms are working
the next step is to get the White House
defenses back online and find out
whether this shd network blackout is
just local or is in fact a global
shutdown
I'm impressed
credit where credit is due
you and your little team of Misfits
managed to decrypt my comms
you passed the test Manny you really do
have an eye for talent first Schaefer
then Lewis and Wally
imagine my surprise when I discovered
you even managed to recruit Vic I
thought you hated him after what
happened at odia
but here you are welcoming old enemies
into your house and giving them the
literal keys to the castle I haven't
decided if you're a genius with
boundless empathy or a [__] who
actually believes that people can change
people don't change
most of the time
if you think someone has changed it's
because you never really saw them you
never look close enough to see if the
person's staring back at you is genuine
or is hiding their true intentions
that's why you're so easy to fool
and why I will always be two steps ahead
of you
I have the Black Tusk the real true sons
and the hunters at my disposal while
your agents have civilians chasing water
bottles
by the way
thank you for sending your agents all
the way to Coney Island to check on
stovepipe
it's too bad you couldn't recruit him
too
but he forgot his place in my
organization and I do not tolerate
disrespect since you may be a [__] I'm
going to make my intentions very clear
this city
this country
this world belongs to us
we will take what is rightfully ours and
there is nothing you can do to stop us
isn't that right Vic
unit
what did you do with Mari and Cindy
don't worry Vic I wouldn't hurt them
they're too valuable to the future of my
operation it's not every day you find a
woman who can build and operate a fish
farm
she really is quite the catch Manny when
you're ready to surrender I would be
more than happy to reunite you two
lovebirds I hear stress can do terrible
things to a pregnancy especially in
older women Manny
if you really do love her
you might want to hurry
oh an agent
I hope to see you soon
the single long condescending comms
pretty much explains everything all
until we've been receiving throughout
this Manhunt has been compromised
whole time everything we've been
listening to has led us to the setup to
have us removed from the equation so
that the black task can sweep in and
clean up the White House while mummy and
daddy went home
it's unlikely that Natalia had anything
to do with the dirty bomb attacks in St
Louis it was just the easiest way of
getting your attention
but it isn't to say that all references
to the recruited novel were just their
disc garrisoned moving out but I'll get
into that a little more soon
Natalia has also confirmed that she has
Vikram Malik a name that we briefly
heard about earlier on after he betrayed
us at the odia tech building as well as
Murray Singh someone we suspected would
have a larger part to play after several
Khan's messages this season alone
she not only leads the team at the
central aquarium one of DC's only
sustainable food sources but she is
pregnant with Manny's child
we're going to have to be careful with
any Direction coming from him after the
loss of his friend and now this is going
to be a mess
but there was one other name that
Natalia mentioned a name I didn't
recognize
Cindy
I'm not gonna lie this is the person
Natalia took I hadn't really paid her
much attention up until now
based in the White House Cindy is a
drone operator that has been involved in
scouting and alerting agents to numerous
threats in DC
it was also her drone that worked the
coordinator gtf and shd work on Coney
Island when extracting Vitale trinenko
as well as the Drone that was hacked by
Aaron Kina before he escaped
I'm not overly sure what Natalia is
hoping to gain from Cindy but I'm sure
we'll be finding out soon
on the way into the White House Black
Tusk operatives could be heard saying
the countermeasure is still active and
while Manny is willing Schaefer out of
the Panic Room he says I overheard
someone say the countermeasures worked
perfectly
given all of the references to the
recruited novel this season I feel that
it's pretty safe to say that this is
another reference to Thomas parrott's
work
in the novel The countermeasure is the
program Myra used to neutralize the
Rogue Network and Tech at the Kansas
core
this essentially keeps the core from
being destroyed by deactivating the EMP
failsafes
Natalia has obviously managed to recover
Myra's code and has used it to shut down
the network and attack the White House
so my question how did Natalia get a
hold of this I don't recall anything
incompromised although I'm not going to
read it for the fourth time just to
confirm this
this will probably be one of those
things about Thomas Parrott and Lauren
Stone about over the coming weeks I've
actually held back on fully talking
about the novels out of respect for the
author and spoilers Etc but now that
we've reached the end of the first novel
in game maybe it's time I have a run
through
this has been a bloody good ending to
the season and year four I was hoping
for it to go out with a bang but I
certainly wasn't expecting this which
makes it so much better
in the interest of keeping this video
somewhat factual so it can be used
towards my own compilation series and
library of videos that I'm thinking may
need to be reviewed sometime soon I'm
going to keep the speculation to a
separate video or two because we have a
number of other things to cover off
before year 5 starts like the perfusion
bio reactor being taken agent Sanders
Cindy McAllister Mari Singh and Vikram
Malik not to mention that we haven't
heard much from Calvin McManus for a
while
anyway thank you very much for watching
hopefully this all made sense and I'll
catch you in the next one extremist
malice extremely remedial
[Music]
[Applause]